the ace lawyer has been a part of the
american cultural lexicon for the better
part of a century
recently re-emerging as a gritty hbo
1930s period piece that stayed faithful
to the novels that inspired it
from the page to the screen here's a
look into the curious case of perry
mason
despite dropping out of law school earl
stanley gardner passed the california
state bar exam
and started working as an attorney in
1911. he specialized in representing
underdogs
particularly immigrant laborers from
mexico and china and spent hours in law
libraries each night after arguing cases
all day
looking for obscure statutes that he
could unleash in court at the perfect
moment
that would become a signature move of
his literary creation perry mason
when in the 1920s gardner adopted a side
hustle of writing legal thrillers
at first gardiner planned to pen novels
about a series of different attorneys
but on the advice of a publisher
he opted to focus solely on mason's
adventures the character debuted in the
1933 novel the case of the velvet
claws a bestseller and the first of
around 80 perry mason mysteries that
gardner would pen
through 1969 the public light gardeners
entertaining amber borderly accurate
courtroom dramas
and he obliged he referred to himself as
the fiction factory
and at one point employed six
secretaries to type out the manuscripts
he dictated into a tape recorder
after he passed away in 1970 the new
york times called gardner the
best-selling american author of the
century
on account of how it moved 170 million
copies
of his perry mason books in the u.s
alone
the perry mason franchise is most famous
for its iterations as a television show
the intense courtroom series starring
raymond burr from the 1950s and 1960s
and the moody 1930s set reimagining with
matthew reese had debuted on hbo in 2020
but long before earl stanley gardner's
popular books about barry mason were
adapted for the small screen
they were successfully converted into
other media formats in 1934
just a year after the first prairie
mason novel delighted readers the first
perry mason movie the case of the
howling dog was released within three
years time
warner brothers would release a total of
six perry mason movies
based on gardner's stories four of them
starring warren william as the world's
greatest attorney
how did you know i went there it's my
business to know things
give me the details the perry mason
radio program a 15-minute cereal that
ran
five afternoons a week from 1943 to 1955
on cbs radio
more closely resembled gardner's crime
and action filled novels
as opposed to the somber
courtroom-dominated tv series
the radio show was popular enough that
in 1956
cbs radio tried to move it format intact
to cbs television
but gardner said no leading the network
to adapt it into the long-running
daytime drama the edge of night
the original perry mason tv series ran
from 1957 to 1966
and as a full season of a show back then
ran around 30 episodes
a whopping 271 installments were
produced
that provided syndicators with a huge
volume of content to rerun on local
stations
hundreds of times over the ensuing 50
odd years perry mason wasn't a
serialized show
each episode generally focused on a
single case wrapped up within the
self-contained story so even dedicated
fans probably wouldn't notice that the
rerun package was one episode short for
years
the oliver twist inspired february 1966
installments the case of the twice told
twist is otherwise a run-of-the-mill
episode
except for the fact that it was produced
in full color the only episode in the
original series run not presented in
black and white
and now we see you for what you really
are as color took hold of tv by the mid
60s
twice told twist was a test to see how
mason would look if it were renewed for
a 10th season
but it wasn't meant to be star raymond
bird told the washington post in 1986
when we got to the end of nine
they asked me for one more year in color
and they shot one show in colour and i
said no
with no tenth season there were no more
color episodes of perry mason
at least not this version of the series
anyway
perry mason was so good at arguing his
case in front of a judging jury that
unlike a real life attorney his win-loss
ratio leaned staggeringly in favor of
the former
268 wins and three losses after all he
was a good guy in the title character
and in the relatively quaint world of
early television it would have been
unthinkable for him to actually lose a
case
in order to balance shocking twists with
his winning record show writers
sometimes used some courtroom
maneuvering
to give the lawyer technical victories
after the fact the 1963 episode the case
of the deadly verdict
begins with a confused mason receiving a
guilty verdict and a death sentence for
his client
accused of murder but then he
investigates and finds a real killer his
lust turns into another win
in 1958 the case of the terrified typist
mason's defendant is found guilty
but is later revealed to be a trickster
pretending to be the real bad guy
your honor this is just another
wild-eyed dramatic grandstand play for
which council is so noted
mason's only actual last came in 1963 as
a case of the witless witness
an episode that begins with the attorney
losing an appeal a rare but relatively
minor loss for the improbably capable
attorney
by the early 1970s the soldier for
decades very recently gone by was in
full swing
fans of 50s culture helped turn greece
into a broadway smash
and make american graffiti a blockbuster
movie on tv
show starring gold favorites and
revivals of classics filled network's
schedules
everything old was new again in 1973
alone
cbs programs the new bill cosby show the
new dick van dyke show and the new perry
mason the original perry mason show had
only been off the air for seven years at
that point and none of the original cast
returned for the reboot
instead of bringing back raymond burr
producers hired lesser known actor monty
marcum to take over for burr in the
iconic role of perry mason
cbs was apparently so confident in the
project that according to markham they
bypassed the pilot and ordered it
straight to series asking for 26
episodes
but only 15 installments aired before
cbs cancelled the new perry mason which
finished the season with low ratings in
1974.
out of 80 shows the new take on an old
favorite reportedly ranked in
at number 71. despite the failure of the
new perry mason on cbs the undefeatable
attorney returned to television a mere
11 years later
this time it was on nbc and in a
different format a succession of
semi-regular made for tv movies this
time bringing back the biggest names
from the original the ones who were
still alive at least
raymond burr returned as perry mason and
so did barbara hale at secretary della
street the role of investigator paul
drake played by the deceased william
hopper was reworked as paul drake jr
and hale's real-life son william katz
took the part perry mason showed up on
tv
three or four times a season for a
two-hour time slot in these formulaic
matlock-esque films
in which a crime was investigated and
then tried in intense courtroom scenes
a total of 26 perry mason movies aired
between 1985
and 1993. perry mason the case of the
killer kiss was the last project
bird would star in with a movie airing
two months after his death the made for
tv mason movies was so reliable for nbc
that the network kept the franchise
going for two years after burst passing
in four movies with the umbrella title
at perry mason mystery
the character perry mason is said to be
out of town and memorable lawyers
anthony caruso
played by paul savino and wild bill
mckenzie played by hal holbrook
argues some very very masonesque cases
in his absence
the perry mason character more or less
died when raymond byrd did in 1993
but in 2011 plans began in earnest to
revive the cracker jack attorney and his
cast of characters for a feature film
starring one of the biggest movie stars
in the world robert downey jr and his
wife producer susan downey
set the project up at warner brothers
with the iron man actor also serving as
the lead actor and co-writer
the script was to be based on a brand
new perry mason story
set in the dark and seedy los angeles of
gardner's novels but he wrote with
production associate david gambino
the movie never got off the ground but
in 2016 the project shifted to hbo where
execs were eager to make a new perry
mason
show and hired true detective creator
nick pizzalatto to write the episodes
a year later however pizzellato had
dropped out in favor of a third season
of true detective and hbo brought in
weeds and friday night lightswriters
roland jones and ron fitzgerald
the series was further delayed when
downey decided to serve only as an
executive producer on perry mason
and not acting it opening the door for
the emmy-winning star of the americans
matthew reese finally in march 2019
hbo officially ordered a mason mini
series
you've done such a great job on this
perry mason
series when matthew reese got the offer
to play perry mason he was initially
skeptical
he recalled in an interview with
collider i got this message saying they
want to talk to you about a remake of
perry mason
and i was like why would you want to
remake perry mason you can't remake
perry mason
i don't know if that's a good idea when
reese receives a full context of the
offer from his agent that it was an hbo
reimagining of perry mason
his interest peaked he said at the pitch
meeting with the producers and writers
i realized very quickly that it wasn't a
remake it's a firm reimagining and a
redefining of perry mason
in a very interesting way then when
production got moving along
reese realized his initial aversion to
stepping into the shoes of a classic
character
was even more misguided because upon
reflection he realized that he had few
concrete preconceived notions of the
show and his main character
he told npr i for one had this image of
who perry mason was and then you have
these vague memories of people
confessing on the stand
but i had no real specifics of perry
mason nevertheless rhys became
interested in the role
finding it to be quote a very dark perry
mason to which i was instantly attracted
he's also not nearly as experienced in
his role as an attorney providing an
opportunity to see the early days of a
fictional icon
much in the same way the movie casino
royale showed a version of secret agent
james bond before he was
you know james bond you may have heard
him i'm new to this
sustained see what i mean the perry
mason of hbo's 2020 reimagining is
nothing like the perry mason of days
past
not yet an established criminal defense
attorney the mason portrayed by matthew
reese is more like the one from
gardner's novels
a broke bitter private detective
complicated and burdened
still suffering from ptsd years after
fighting in world war one
haunted by a divorce and self-medicating
with alcohol
you're terrible are you drunk probably
jesus
perry despite putting all of its
significant resources into producing and
promoting its perry mason origin series
hbo apparently didn't have exceptionally
high expectations for how the series
would perform
according to entertainment weekly the
network initially billed the program as
a one-off mini-series
that way if it failed to attract viewers
over the course of its eight episodes
the network could limit the perception
of failure
but all of that trepidation was for
naught the series premiere episode in
june 2020
attracted 1.7 million viewers the cable
service's biggest debut in two years
out drawing recent hits like the
outsider and watchman within a month
perry mason had an audience of 8 million
leading hbo to reclassify the show
and then renew it for season 2. check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you